people never lie so much as before an
election
during a war
or after a hunt
only a fool learns from his own mistakes
the wise man learns from the mistakes of
others
we live in a wondrous time
in which the strong are weak
because of their scruples and the weak
grow strong
because of their audacity
man cannot control the current of events
he can only float with them and steer
when you want to fool the world
tell the truth
preventive war is like committing
suicide out of fear of death
laws are like sausages
it's better not to see them being made
it is the destiny of the weak
to be devoured by the strong
people light
right diplomatically
even in the declaration of war one
observes the rules of politeness
politics is the art of the possible
the attainable
the art of the next best
never believe anything in politics until
it has been officially denied
politics is not an exact science
hounds follow those who feed them
the great questions of the day will not
be settled by means of speeches and
majority decisions
but by iron and blood
the main thing is to make history
not to write it
political judgment is the ability to
hear the distant hoof beats
of the horse of history
a conquering army on the border
will not be stopped by eloquence
life is like being at the dentist
you always think that the worst is still
to come
and yet it is over already
what we learned from history
is that no one learns from history
the life of a man is like a game of
chess
which he plays according to his art
a rich society must care for the poor
woe to the leader whose arguments at the
end of a war
are not as plausible
as they were at the beginning
if you want to build socialism
choose a country that you don't care for
[Music]
beer makes you lazy
stupid
and powerless
anyone who has ever looked into the
glassy eyes of a soldier dying on the
battlefield
will think twice before starting a war
freedom is a luxury
that not everyone can afford
one and only one person must be
responsible for every assigned task
with bad laws and good officials
it is quite possible to rule the country
but if the officials are bad
even the best laws will not help
stupidity
is a gift from god
but it should not be abused
life has taught me a lot to forgive
but even more to seek forgiveness
the attitude of the state towards the
teacher is a state policy
that testifies either to the strength of
the state
or to its weakness
when the arguments end
the guns begin to speak
strength is the last argument of a
dullard
i was destined by nature to become a
diplomat
i was born on the 1st of april
friendship between a man and a woman is
very weak at nightfall
the strong are always right
never trust russians because russians
don't even trust themselves
the government should not hesitate
once having chosen the road
it must without looking back
to the right and left
go to the end
we are all a people
and so is the government
a wise person is only one who knows not
much
but the necessary
even a victorious war is an evil
that must be averted by the wisdom of
the nations
with a gentleman i am always a gentleman
and a half
and with a fraud
i try to be a fraud
and a half
avoid people who try to diminish your
ambitions
when you say you agree to a thing in
principle
you mean that you have not the slightest
intention of carrying it out in practice
always beware of building castles in the
air
these buildings are the easiest to build
but the hardest to destroy
all treaties between great states
cease to be binding
when they come in conflict with the
struggle for existence
fools say that they learn by experience
i prefer to profit from others
experience
the statesman's task is to hear god's
footsteps marching through history and
to try to catch on to his coattails
as he marches past
great men
have great dogs
a really great man is known by three
signs
generosity in the design
humanity in the execution
moderation in success
we germans fear god
but nothing else in the world
a little caution outflanks a large
cavalry
my subject is my life
and my life is my subject
i'm accustomed to paying men back in
their own coin
better pointed bullets than pointed
speeches
show me an objective worthy of war
and i will go along with you
beware of sentimental alliances
where the consciousness of good deeds is
the only compensation for noble
sacrifices
appreciate your traitor
because a traitor is the best teacher
the more you think about money
the more you spend it
avoid a friend who knows everything
about you
you